you mentioned in the film about your own
reticence with people your shyness and
there's been a part of you that it feels
like I think to a lot of the public has
been closed off at times yeah and this
is this documentary the first time
you've really decided to be upfront with
everything personal life professional a
lot of aspects why now what kind of
moved you at this moment in your life to
be to kind of share some of these things
that you had been holding back a little
bit well you know my dad passed away in
2005 and in the eight years between when
my mom passed away and when my dad
passed away I got to know my dad in ways
that I'd never known him my whole life
and it really had to do with I'm a lot
like my dad I'm I don't talk very much
and it really kept me from understanding
him until he needed me to to take care
of him
and I learned things about him that that
I had known and I didn't want to go
through that with my own children and
any people that I had known that might
have been put off by my shyness you know
so I figured I'd come forth and speak on
that on those subjects now while I still
remember you know it's hard to get all
the facts of your your life down and
mash them into 30 into 90 minutes but we
managed to do it I think they did a
great job I can imagine that was
actually very challenging I mean
partially the recollection and then
deciding you know what to to say what to
still maybe withhold in going through
that did you find it served the purpose
that you kind of hoped it would and in
terms of whether it was the influence
from from your father you know before he
passed and then this this openness that
you'd kind of inspired you to to have
did it did the movie the documentary
feel that way that you were kind of
relaxing about about these things now
well it felt like I I was willing to
open up and answer questions on whatever
subject we had to go through a lot of
decision making with regard to what we
would cover
in depth and what was not that important
so you know that was the back and forth
on the decision-making as to what we
really got into it in the film there are
a lot of I mean sensitive moments in
this in this film sensitive issues to do
with your family in particular the
separation or the the difficulty of
being away from your kids a lot during
your playing career the the estrangement
for a time from your parents then you
you kind of go head on with those were
those how difficult was it to finally
kind of discuss some of those things in
a public way I was surprised that it
wasn't that difficult it's just I want
you to make a decision you follow
through with it and let the chips fall
but I didn't think that telling the
truth about my life was gonna negatively
impact my life that much at this point
so I went on ahead and did it and you
know you saw interviews within the
documentary of your son's who speaking
obviously very candidly themselves was
that a nice aspect of this to kind of
involve them in a way that you know
obviously they they're not involved in
your playing life but in this particular
you know endeavor they're they're you
know they're obviously part of the story
how was it to have them involved it was
great having my son's involved and my
son's got to know all the guys on the
Showtime team pretty well because I
often would bring them to practice so
they they knew all of these people that
were talking in the film and they had
memories of their interactions with them
and just what having to deal with me
being a professional athlete what it was
all about a lot of the film and again
just kind of reiterated by the title is
just you know that there's a very solo
aspect to to your life especially early
on and through your career and you you
talk a lot about there's a quote from
you actually where you say I'm just a
person like any other person you you fit
the the basketball side fine but the
fame part of the celebrity was
always uneasy for you it seems is that
you feel still the case to this day does
that ever change over time I've been
dealing with celebrity and just sticking
out for so long and I don't know
anything else I haven't had any other
experience where I had anonymity or I
fit in I certainly don't disappear in a
crowd you can see that from the opening
shots where I'm like walking in Times
Square and I stick out you know that
that's just been a part of my life that
I had to accommodate do you think you're
more comfortable with your celebrity
your fame your sticking out now than you
were thirty years ago well yeah I've
learned how to cope with it and I've
dealt with some some of the issues a lot
of times you don't draw positive
attention especially if you run into a
lot of Nick for hands or Celtics fans
you know yeah but it's it I didn't mind
doing it you know it ended up being the
right thing to do
yeah as that part of you changed a
little bit just because it's you know a
certain point this this just is reality
do you find yourself at all more at ease
now whether it's crowds or people you
know seeking you out to you know say hey
big fan and these kinds of things I
think I'm dealing with it better I don't
know if I like it anymore but I'm
dealing with it in a more in an easier
way it's it's something that I've
accepted and when you accept that this
is what you have to deal with it you
find ways to accommodate it that don't
put a whole lot of stress on your life
your social activism and your your
social conscience which is something
that is obviously very prominent to this
day you're you know accomplished author
essayist scholar you are still very
plugged into you know you know the
issues of our time we see some of that
early on in the documentary - what were
some of the first triggers for that for
you to kind of get involved to decide
you know what I'm not just an athlete
I'm you know a member of the society and
there are there are things I need to
speak about
I'd say the very first one was the
murder of Emmett Till I was 8 years old
when he got murdered and I didn't
understand what had happened you know I
was old enough to kind of grasp that he
had done something wrong but I I
couldn't figure out what it was and my
parents couldn't explain it to me you
know they didn't have the words for it
they really hadn't thought about all the
issues and figured it out in terms of
being able to explain it to a to a child
so I was very keenly interested in what
happened during the civil rights
movement and I followed it closely
there's a picture of being there at a
news conference with dr. King I got to
ask him a question you know and and talk
with him it really really affected me
just to interact with with him within
five years of the that four years of
that incident he had been assassinated
so a lot of this really was personal you
know just having to do with my own
personal experiences and what I'd seen
happening in America I was recruited by
a number of schools in the South at a
time when all the schools down there was
segregated and you know that that had
its effect on me and my outlook so a lot
of these things cross over in my life
what was the first thing you can
remember actually taking more of a
public stand on or participating in that
kind of maybe set you apart a little
where you then had to deal with a little
bit of the backlash she's I think the
Harlem riot of in summer of 64 I covered
it as a correspondent for our weekly
newspaper that I was involved with it
was a summer job set up it was what was
I forget the exact excuse me I'm not
sure I'm at a loss for words here it was
it was a summer program set up to show
the kids in Harlem give them an
opportunity to learn about their
community and what they could do to make
it a better place and it was a very
important thing in my life dr. Clark is
the one who set the program up and it
really enabled me to understand what my
community was all about what Harlem was
all about and how important it was for
black Americans and it really had a
profound effect on me and I I'd say that
that changed my life because he helped
me to understand what was going on in
this country and what had to be done
about it or at least start thinking
about what what could be done about it
yeah I'm curious your view now of how
today's athletes are dealing with issues
of the day because you know the modern
athlete has often been criticized for
being a little more disengaged or for
caring only about you know the you know
the Paycheck or the endorsements or not
wanting to you know alienate corporate
America or mainstream America but in the
last couple of years especially in the
NBA it feels like there's been more of a
movement to engage LeBron James has been
very out front recently talking about
gun control he and his teammates in
Miami had made a statement during the
Trayvon Martin case and you know time
after time the t-shirts with I can't
breathe last season so there's been more
of that I'm curious do you do you find
that encouraging that you know these are
maybe baby steps they're not a margin
estreet sput do you see that that there
is a higher consciousness now and more
of a willingness to engage I definitely
appreciate the the consciousness aspect
of it because these are young men that
are concerned about what's happening in
our country and really I don't see any
difference between what they are doing
and their connection with the civil
rights movement because
it's still an extension of that same
civil rights movement the the issue that
summer of 64 was an unarmed black kid
getting shot in the streets of Harlem
and over the past couple of years we've
seen a number of deaths of unarmed black
youth that were killed by police and law
enforcement that really leave a lot of
questions so we're still dealing with
the same issues and I think that it's
really all part of the same the same
piece it's all has to do with civil
rights and human rights and these people
are concerned I remembered the there
were a couple players on the Cleveland
Browns who were very upset about the
killing of Tamir rice and they were
worried about it because they were
parents and they could see where Tamir
rice could have been their kid and
that's something that really makes you
stop and think you know hey my my kid
could get shot down in the street just
because he of the color of his skin and
he it was playing with it with a toy
pistol and he shot dead on Christmas Day
it's a really horrible event and we have
to we have to do something about
affecting that you think there's to that
end is there even more that today's
athletes with the stage that they have
could be should be doing or do you try
not to maybe you know lecture the next
generation about about where they could
go with that because it seems like
there's a line that they won't cross
that there may be a statement there may
be a shortage Esther but it seems like
there's there's a you know another place
they won't go
III don't know that I think that that
would probably be something that you'd
have to find out by talking to each act
lead individually and finding out what
their opinion was and how concerned they
were about that yeah if you don't mind
actually I just thinking about this I
mean the thabo sefolosha case obviously
happening you know which happened right
here in New York a current NBA player
and certainly that had a lot of players
concerned about you know
their teammate their colleague did that
one in particular resonate too because
again this is you know police brutality
is one of the things that animated you
early on and also i curious about you
know your own father and grandfather
were we're police officers I imagine
there's a certain complexity in your own
thinking there just because of you've
seen many aspects of these relations
yeah I have and you know police police
officers have incredibly difficult jobs
and we need them they are they are the
blue line between you know order and
chaos so you know we have to respect
them and try to make their jobs doable
but at the same time they have to
respect the people that they are put out
there to protect and serve I mean it's
it's a two-way street and I I don't
think there are they're always conscious
of that you know the police officers
sometimes get a little bit arrogant with
their power and you know look down on
the people that they're supposed to be
protecting and serving did you take an
interest in the Sefolosha case because
of your own history of in these issues
yeah I did take an interest in but you
got to let the the the process work
itself out you know so there's a jury
listening to this case and they'll know
a lot more about it than I would because
you know I wasn't there and I don't know
who's exactly telling the truth and you
know what's going on with that I'm sure
that it will work itself out hopefully
to everybody's satisfaction these are
the kind of issues I mean you you write
about these things all the time you've
got the the regular standing essays in
Time magazine and these are issues that
you address all the time you are more
these days obviously an you know author
scholar filmmaker than almost anything
else and it's been 26 years since your
retirement but most introductions are
still and here's hall-of-famer all-time
scoring here Kareem abdul-jabbar
I get the sense sometimes that you would
prefer those things to be reversed now
that that you know you've it's been a
while since since you were that Kareem
abdul-jabbar do you find that part of it
still I won't say difficult it's
obviously part of your legacy but do you
feel like that people love you and you
kind of put an athlete in a box and then
it's well this is this is who you are
you're over here well you know I I don't
I don't know it's it's a mixed bag I'm
very happy that people know who I am
that that gives me the opportunity to
when I write people who know who I am
might be more interested in what I'm
writing so you know I'm I don't reject
it but I think it has to be dealt with
in perspective as you mentioned I've
been retired for 26 years a whole lot
has happened since then and I'm doing
different things now so people gonna
have to get used to that you've also
been to that end I mean you're very
active in social media you've got a
Twitter account with I don't know how
many followers you've blown my follower
count out of the water a long time ago
that's all I know
um but there's an interaction that can
go on there how much do you find
yourself either responding to or at
least you check the replies are you
curious because you know you write a lot
of things that are obviously on some
polarizing issues that there's gonna be
a response there you know I've gotten my
share of hate mail absolutely some of
the stances I've taken have annoyed
various people just because they have a
certain point of view when it conflicts
with mine so but I you know I've got to
accept that and I have to deal with that
the irony there I think people would see
this like there was you know and you
talk about this at lainson in the
documentary that you know your your
relations with the media wasn't always
great a little a little frosty you you
even say at some point that you felt
like that really did hurt you this is a
new era where athletes celebrities of
all stripes can you know put their
message out there any time on social
media Twitter or otherwise do you find
that to be kind of a freeing thing that
you
can you know whatever the narrative may
be whether it's about yourself or about
issues that you are passionate about
you've got a more of a direct line now
than you would have ever had when you
were much more in the spotlight as a
player yeah I think the ability to
directly interact with the public at
large allows my thoughts to be conveyed
without having to go through the filter
of someone who was interviewing me and
might have their own biases so I think
that's good when I started playing I had
to deal with a very conservative core of
press people who thought that you know
athletes are out there to play the game
and keep your mouth shut
except if they're answering questions
that the press one day asked them and
you know we had a place and we were
supposed to stay in our place and I
never agreed with that and I I had my
own opinions and I was willing to defend
them and I guess that made me somewhat
of a maverick and that's one of the
reasons that the relationship kind of
was as difficult as it was you wonder
how different it might have been if
you'd actually had the the Avenue the
tool of social media in your own time
oh yeah probably would have been quite
different because I could have given my
opinion and not have to have other
people put their two cents into it and
try to spin it there's not anything in
particular in the documentary where
where it gets into that where you felt
either burned or mischaracterized so I
am curious were there a couple of those
moments or one that sticks out in
particular where you really felt like
either the fact that you've been
standoffish with the press or just
whatever you their agenda might have
been at the time where you felt that
that really had had hurt you
well there was an interview I did with
Joe Garagiola where he suggested that if
I didn't like what was happening in the
country that I should leave the country
because
you didn't like the tone of what I had
to say and the fact that I was not going
to go to the Olympics and you know that
he was pretty direct about it and at
least in that interview I got to give my
opinion but that's what I was up against
you know that the people that were
interviewing me and trying to convey my
thoughts really had their own biases and
they were going to give precedence to
their opinions as opposed to mine yeah
how did you deal with it then was it
just to simply withdraw or were there
you know other ways and then how
frustrating must that have been for
someone who is obviously as outspoken
and you know as you are to have to not
you know engage or have that that
ability to kind of come back it was it
was difficult it was a hard thing to do
but I think that a lot of people saw
through the attempts at manipulation and
figured out what I was all about so I
think more often than not I got my point
across lighter note the the documentary
does spend a couple of minutes talking
about your friendship with Bruce Lee and
the film you did with him it goes into
airplane one of my all-time favorites
and then Arsenio Hall actually says like
wow there's you know Kareem you know
laughing and joking and then what a
great revelation that was that you know
that your even your friends saw for you
feeling like either they wished it
seemed like that that the public got to
see that more often
what was that those moments like for you
do you feel like maybe you could have
done or should have done more just so
the public could see kind of that the
you know humorous side well I think as
the 80s went on and Lakers started
winning games and the press wasn't
asking me how come the Lakers did not
win the World Championship with with you
on the team well we were winning world
war championships and I think
playing with magic made that a lot
easier because he was a darling of the
media and it's just lighting the whole
mood up and allowed me to put some of
the the ill-will behind me the Bruce Lee
in particular and in our younger viewers
probably don't know who Bruce Lee is
they'll have to go google it look up
Wikipedia but most young people know who
Bruce Lee do that yeah well the t-shirts
are still around everywhere right like
yeah we've become one of those iconic
figures that you know even if you didn't
know him or see his movies they all
watch I'm amazed at it you know because
I talk to people all the time and you
want to see what what was Bruce Lee
actually like yeah there's still
curiosity about him I think that that
particular chapter of your life and
people are probably less aware of give
us a little sense of what Bruce Lee was
was like and how did that relationship
that friendship evolved well I started
studying martial arts basically with my
dad teaching me how to box but as I went
through college I started to become
curious about oriental martial arts and
one of the people at black belt magazine
I got a chance to know him and he
introduced me to Bruce he said Jesus if
he wanna study martial arts he should go
and meet this guy Bruce Lee's very
interesting he's doing his own thing so
I was curious enough to go and have a
meeting with him I immediately went over
to to Bruce his personality was more or
less irresistible and we became friends
and I trained with him for four years
but you know the friendship was really
the most important part of it for me and
it was a great thing and I miss him good
guy what was he like I mean he strikes
me as somebody who had a certain kind of
you know mister of a sense of humor
about him this is the sense of humor he
was a practical joker and
it was someone that really you would
want to know he's that kind of person
he's always kept a mood light and always
was the he never felt that he was here
and you were there you know he he dealt
with everybody giving them the
opportunity to be themselves and as long
as they accepted him for who he was you
know did you ever have a temptation
after doing you know martial arts movie
with Bruce Lee and doing that the cameo
and airplane did was there a temptation
to move further in that direction
explored a little or was that just kind
of a all right I've had my my fill have
done that well you know Bruce died geez
when I was like twenty four years old
twenty four twenty five years old when
Bruce died and he wasn't there that's
why I you know I tell people how I miss
him you know just the relationship
didn't get a chance to have fifteen or
twenty years of interaction in terms of
just like the grand scope of this movie
because we see a lot there's a lot of
basketball interspersed with
interspersed with a lot of just those
personal moments personal feelings
relationships what are the things that
you're hoping the most that people can
kind of take away from this that if it
feels like that they didn't have a
chance to kind of get to know you before
what are you hoping they most come away
with with this film well I just hope
that they can realize that the reason
that I was so hard to to understand was
had to do with my shyness and my
reticence to to talk to people that I
thought might be looking to make me look
bad you know that that was how my
relationship with the press develop and
part of that had to do with the fact
that when I was at UCLA coach wouldn't
told us and not to talk to the press he
felt that they could be a distraction
and you know there was there was more
negative that could come about from that
interaction than positive and that type
of suspicion
and you know standoffish this really did
not serve me well as a professional
athlete professional athletes have to
work with the press our jobs go hand in
hand and you have to accept that and
deal with it so you know that I think
that really that set of circumstances
was something that it took me a while to
to figure out and and navigate in a way
that I could accept you would do it
differently now you think oh absolutely
I do it differently you know I started
doing it differently while I was still
playing not soon enough to maybe turn
the tide of the opinion like that the
caricatures had already been drawn that
this is this Kareem he's gonna be a
little standoffish and yeah I was
already cast as the moody black guy and
you know it was hard to escape that
caricature when you say at one point in
the movie that you thought that did hurt
you did you think that that hurt you
even within NBA corridors that for the
longest time I know you wanted to get
into coaching and it seemed like it was
difficult to break through until you
know you know I think the Clippers and
then the Lakers following that right but
it always the NBA part of it always had
to do with the fact that a lot of the
teams felt that I was too much my own
man and I would be a difficult person to
have as a head coach so I didn't get
that opportunity you did you know the
last tourney you took on that that stage
was working with the Lakers and working
with Bynum it's been a while now have
you had any impulse to go back or you
kind of content with the path you're
taking now I've had a couple guys come
to me and ask me to to work with him yo
Keem Noah came and she's just like two
or three two or three years ago but I
worked with him and helped him the next
year he was Defensive Player of the Year
I felt that had something to do with
that and then roy hibbert also asked me
to come and work with him he's with the
Lakers now I might have a chance to
to put a few words in his ear at this
point but I think that I could have had
a good career as a coach but I never got
the opportunity so we'll never know
there's a couple moments in the movie
where you know Riley and some former
teammates and even opponents are
marveling about the skyhook when these
guys come to you does anybody ever ask
to be taught the skyhook and obviously
no one has really tried you know in a
major way to incorporate it in their
game yeah I know I I don't get why
people don't try to learn the hook shot
you don't have to suit it like I shot it
but the mechanics of it make it a very
difficult shot to block and you can get
your body in close to the basket you're
taking a six to eight foot shot that's a
high percentage shot a lot of players
could benefit from that but it doesn't
seem like it's it's in style and I think
a lot more of that has to do with the
popularity of the three-point shot you
know everybody wants to like lotto fever
you know the money as three as opposed
to two and you know they they don't get
the idea of a high percentage shot being
more beneficial to a team than a
three-point shot yeah
I remembered the playoffs who played
against the Celtics in 85 the law the
most number of three-point shots that
were taken in the whole series I think
was like seven or eight I think the
Memorial Day Massacre Boston made seven
three-point shots now in days don't take
20 shots and a half will be three-point
shots so by putting a premium on a low
percentage shot it's changed the nature
of the game you think that's for the
worse for the better just just different
I mean do you enjoy watching it it's
different I don't enjoy watching it as
much but I think the fans liked it so
it's gonna remain part of the game it's
funny because you know it just in terms
of pace you know the Warriors style has
been an
to show time just you know if nothing
else that it's the up and back the
three-point part of it is obviously much
different but you do you see that at all
or is that kind of a you know a bad
analogy stand from the Showtime
standpoint I think it's a bad analogy
because we played the game differently
at both ends of the court and we had an
inside-outside thing going at Showtime
the Warriors don't have too much going
inside but they have absolutely shot the
lights out I saw a thing on Stefan curry
where he was practicing three-point shot
see he made 77 in a row 92 out of 100
that's incredible I never saw anybody
shoot like that that type of
consistently consistency from that range
is pretty remarkable and when you got
people that can shoot like that you
should let them go I mean as I say it's
a copycat league so this pace in space
and three-point shooting that's become
the trend but things kind of move around
do you see a time when the the big man
becomes more featured again becomes more
important again can it can it swing back
or does it maybe take a transcendent
kind of player like a Kareem or a Shaq
or you know what type to come along to
maybe force it in that direction I think
a player that can deliver in the paint
would change people's minds again
because the closer you get to the basket
the higher your shooting percentage goes
and coaches are aware of that so I think
that if you get somebody that can
deliver in there consistently that it
might change but you know trends are or
what they are and we just have to wait
and see there's that moment in the
documentary that everybody remembers of
the the rocking chair this uncomfortable
slightly but humorous light-hearted
moment on your farewell tour the rocking
chair did when you got to that 20th year
did you know immediately did you know
beforehand when did you decide
you know what this is when took to close
this chapter how did you know I knew
that I needed to retire when it was
getting difficult for me to live up to
the standards that I had set for myself
personally I could could see that either
I wasn't interested or I was losing that
that mythical half-step so you know III
really didn't have any problem leaving
the game when I did I probably could
have played a little bit longer if they
had gone to chartering planes because I
would have gotten more rest and been
able to deal with the widget travel
schedule but you know that's hindsight
that that moment it seems like it's
tough for a lot of athletes to come to
grips with especially the greats and I'm
thinking about Kobe Bryant right now
entering his 20th season with the Lakers
and kind of declining to say whether
this might be it for for him and he
seems like you know knowing Kobe that he
might just keep pushing the envelope and
he's gone through now three consecutive
major injuries can you on a just a
psychological level emotional level
knowing the attachment to the game and
and the high highs that you can have
especially as one of the all-time greats
can you feel a little bit about what
he's going through wrestling with that
yeah I understand what he's going
through and it's very difficult to
accept your own decline there are a lot
of things that give you indications that
you're not really declining yeah so you
it's a very difficult thing and it's up
to the individual really to to figure it
out and not hold on for too long
do you find yourself I mean I'm wincing
a little bit maybe even that you know
what because you see I mean these are
but serious injuries the Achilles the
knee the shoulder it almost feels like
he's defying his own body basically
saying you know I get to decide you know
when when to go
and you know when you're 25 years old
that that's really easy and your body
still has the ability to heal itself but
as you get closer to that that 40 that
number 40 it gets more and more
difficult so I think that you know it's
up to code we though you know he's he
doesn't have anything to prove and if he
walks away from the game right now it
nobody couldn't say a thing he's proven
that he's one of the all-time greats of
the game yeah no doubt last thing here
would on the documentary at the end
there's this kind of poignant moment and
you know the voice-over is you know
after all he's been through he's free
are you feeling that especially with
kind of completing this particular
project and what this project represents
is this you know you feeling free now
well yeah I feel free not just because I
adjusted to living a life probably I
could have started writing 20 25 years
ago well actually I did start writing 20
25 years ago but I could have been more
enthusiastic about it and I was just
trying it as something to do even though
I understood that I had the training and
I had the mindset to apply myself that
way but it took a while before I got to
the point where I could be comfortable
with it and I'm comfortable with it now
thank you very much Kareem abdul-jabbar
the documentary is Kareem minority of
one catch it on HBO and thanks again for
joining us related thank you